welcome to the Macmillan report I'm
Marilyn Wilkes your host and our guest
is Catherine pantera brick a professor
of anthropology health and global
affairs at yale university professor
panter bricks research consists of
critical analyses of health and
well-being across key stages of human
development giving special attention to
the impact of poverty disease
malnutrition armed conflict and social
marginalization her focus on children in
global adversity has included
biocultural research with street
children refugees and war affected
adolescents she is published widely on
child and adolescent health including
articles on conflict and mental health
and Afghanistan household
decision-making and infant survival in
famine-stricken Niger the social ecology
of growth retardation in Nepali slums
biomarkers of stress in the context of
violence and homelessness and the
effectiveness of public health and
humanitarian interventions today we talk
with Professor pantera brick about
research she's done on the role fathers
play in parenting welcome professor
Panther Breck Thank You Marilyn is a
pleasure to be here so let's start with
an overview of the work tell us about it
so we completed a study on of parenting
interventions globally around the world
that engage with men in their role as
fathers okay and fathers matters for
many many different reasons they matter
for children for families and for global
citizenship and we argue in the study
that it's the further factor that we
forget to leverage in mothering and in
parenting interventions that are
essentially gender blind and focus on
mothers instead of co parents and so we
call this a father factor or the
Forgotten phyla factor
in research practice and policy okay and
what kind of interventions did you look
at we looked at mostly parenting
interventions that are there's a huge
diversity of interventions throughout
the world so their home-based visit
Hospital based interventions community
based intervention interventions to
bring inmates or socioeconomically
disadvantaged parents or first-time
parents who have married the mothers all
on board for effectively care of
caregiving of the child and their
thickness three levels at which father's
matter okay the first is for the child
so they matter for their social
emotional and physical well-being they
matter for their educational outcomes
they matter for their life satisfaction
for their capacity for empathy and all
those aspects that we know well they're
also matters for the families for
mothers and helping mothers and issue of
a gender equity in the home and I think
the most exciting dimension is the
matter for global citizenship because
the way that a child has been raised
influences the way that child raises
their children and so you have parental
skills social skills mental half
disposition to violence all cascading
from one generation to the other so if
you take settings like conflict settings
you have a perpetuation of violence or
the ability to break the transmission of
violence from one generation to the
other through raising our children more
effectively we simply argue that fathers
have been forgotten in that equation
that they've been that the role is
sometimes sidelined and sometimes
undermined and we want to cast more
attention on those okay so what was the
impetus behind you taking on this work
so it was really a partnership between
scholars practitioners and advocates for
policymaking in the study that we
published in the Journal of child
psychology and psychiatry there's
sixteen members four of them are at Yale
the Yale child study center the
Macmillan Center anthropology and
Jackson Institute and two of them are
from the fatherhood Institute in London
and so as well it was inserted within a
wider conversation with NGOs that are
invested in the caregiving of children
and big organization like UNICEF it was
really prompted by a conversation we had
with the Turkish mother child foundation
who have implemented mother support
programs workshops that are geared
towards mothers and their children for
25 years in in Turkey and a program
that's implemented a national level and
they have just recently launched a
father support program because the
Turkish mothers came to the organization
and said look we can't implement
everything that you've taught us at home
with our children if the men are going
to be obstacles at home so please bring
them on board so they had this father
support group which is originally
Auxiliary and then they discovered that
fathers really really matter and so I
think they were the one who made a
stumble upon the importance of fathers
but we were the one who set that
evidence on a scientific global
perspective okay so let's talk about the
methodology of your work so the
methodology was a systematic review of
the literature so we really had to do
two kinds of searches one of them is the
very standard literature search over at
what time period just one year okay I
mean I mean we took a year but the their
parenting interventions that those that
exist forever okay and that captures the
very best known interventions in the
world today and then we did a second
search automatic search to get to the
most to the ones that don't don't get
published in the literature and
discovered parenting interventions and
places like Ukraine pyronesia Jordan
Pakistan and other places how did you
get at that secondary level aspesi be
difficult to go through contacts through
websites 31 a good example of the UNICEF
programs that are rolled out across the
world
so through a detective work that's
two-pronged approach between the
systemic and the sleuth right finding
put those articles together so in the
end we ended up with a thousand articles
that were parenting interventions with
dads on board not just mothering
interventions and we just in about 20
different countries and we looked at
those pretty closely okay so what do you
think the implications of this study are
well for for one it's it's not a very
good idea to sidelined importance of
fathers and for a second we need a
policy change at the highest level in
terms of the design of our interventions
that can sideline them so we have no
means of really effectively evaluating
or engaging with men and it's not that
we want to just engage with men as
opposed to mothers but we want to
leverage co-parenting if possible and we
want to find out find out what works
best in particularly particular context
so to give you an example my favorite
example is the in nazare equalled amake
which means school for husbands which
will men joined when they get married in
order to get schooled into the skills of
being fathers and husbands and they
learn about gender equity and their
power to to give children access to
education and care so of course many
other decision-makers so the stakes are
very high but it's a lovely way of
bringing on board the men now the good
example in Brazil is the work from
instituto profundo bro mundo that looks
at ways of redefining the masculinity of
men so that they move away from a
disposition of violence and domestic
violence inside their home and really
become effective caregivers and more
have more equitable relationships with
their partner so we there are
interventions that really demonstrate
that fatherhood is a transformative
moment for men that they want to raise
their children in a different way and we
can move them away from that disposition
of violence harsh parenting disciplining
masculinity
a world view towards one that makes them
really engage in raising the Generation
Next Generation 44 empathetic and
peaceful more peaceful young men and
women which we think is very important
of course it sounds you know very
idealistic and I wonder you know in
thinking of certain countries it must be
very difficult to institute those kinds
of changes in certain places in the
world that have from a cultural
perspective men being very you know the
ruler yeah the macho right but but you
can you mean how do you work around them
that's what a very interesting way of
doing things that we don't know it fits
the best but this is one that seems to
prove good in certain respects is a
men-only workshop where instead of
bringing women and then together you
give a platform for men to discuss these
issues and they're quite surprised to
find that other men have these kinds of
problems etcetera and find their
strategies find such as used to move
forward so yes things are very difficult
a great example would be Northern
Ireland for peacebuilding in terms of
bringing together growth of Catholics
and Protestants that are coming to the
table with the same idea which is that
their children should not go through
that and they have to raise that
children in a different way and so these
sometimes these men men only group or
even co-parent groups you you learn to
overcome the stereotype that you might
have towards the other which is why we
certainly think that men only group or
co-parent group I'd be more effective
than just home visits because they make
you relate to other people across the
ethnic religious or social divide and
that has the potential for breaking down
some stereotypes and we do find that in
certain places in the world and you know
you have to have the same aspiration for
your children and that's a very good
pathway so we have a book coming out
myself Jim lachman and remus all at
UNICEF called pathway
two piece where we put together this
idea or review the concrete evidence
that we go from the biology of the brain
to peacebuilding in ways that the you
know the standard idea is that the way
we raise our children will matter for
Health and Social Development now the
big new idea the bold idea is that the
way we reserve children will matter for
peacebuilding and and and that's a hot
subject and the conversation is really
percolating at the highest levels of
policymaking for instance in the United
Nations there's great excitement at this
idea that we could do peace building
through grassroot family and children
focus policies that seems to be a nice
pathway that's practical grounded and
yet achieves the big goals of making the
world a better place for our children
right now without losing more time right
it sounds like a wonderful idea I just
wonder how how difficult it is to
actually implement you know for instance
I think of you know I just was speaking
with someone about the Central Africa
Republic which of course is you know in
the midst of a war and it's a very
diffuse situation so that comes to mind
we're in terms of you know in terms of
the policy that you're speaking about
would probably work very well there but
I'm wondering how difficult it is to get
those kinds of programs grow you know
going yeah we think it is much of having
some advocates and partnership between
the media the parents themselves and the
and the structures do to enable them to
give them the wherewithal to raise their
children in that possible way but a
great example of media action for
instance would be the african fatherhood
initiative that puts out posters with a
man and a baby saying it takes a man to
be a dad and that's a lovely way of
saying dads don't think that babies are
the realm of women
right because we know from the biology
of parenting or caregiving that it takes
about 15 minutes for hormonal change to
happen to a man when you give a baby and
the more experienced the manners of the
father but the quickest these hormonal
changes are happening principally
oxytocin the hormone of love and that
Prime's a man to move away from
competition and aggression to care and
love so we think we can leverage some
kind of biology in having men engage
with babies so that the attachment is
very strong and basically structure the
brains of men and babies in ways that
primed them towards empathy and social
relationship rather than aggression fear
and punishment I think that is an
important piece of the scientific
evidence but that alone is not going to
make it happen so we have with partners
established a or advocated towards a
early child consortium and peacebuilding
consortium and it was launched at the UN
a year ago we go back to the UN very
regularly there was the International
University of the International Year of
the family most recently there was the
United Nations General Assembly forum on
peace and so this conversation are
having are happening at the very high
level as well as in particular places in
disadvantaged neighborhoods like in in
Turkey in Brazil India share and in
Central African Republic so I think the
the global picture best there's a will
there to change things and we just need
to see the way with all the big point is
that parenting skills are not just
mothering skills that the we need to
have better means of leveraging that
father factor that we think is really
the missing ingredient the game change
in a parenting intervention would be to
bring on board the men just as strongly
as you've bought on board the women and
if I can give you another example of a
media campaign there's the he for she
campaign meaning that you don't look
after women by just advocating just
having the women advocate for themselves
engaging the men that really is the game
change or really matters so it's that
vision
and that and then putting the policies
that that don't undermine that vision
that is really important and the
excitement I think is when the science
and the policy and the practice are
coming all together and not at odds with
each other and I think that moment is
coming right I agree so that's great
well thank you very much for being here
today and sharing some of your work it's
fascinating Thank You Marilyn so we need
to make the most of fathers i believe
yes i agree i agree thank you thank you
having for more information about
professor panther brooke and her work
please visit our website at yale edu
slash McMillan report be sure to join us
again for another episode of the
McMillan report made possible through
funding from the Whitney and Betty
Macmillan Center for International and
area studies at ya
you